Jeremy Foley, Filmmaker/Actor/Screenwriter: Oh
man, no the Red Wedding was in [episode] three.
I can’t put that last. Oh boy!
People will never forgive me.
Film Courage: Do you have a strong opinion about
what happened with Game of Thrones, Jeremy?
Jeremy:Yes, I do have a strong opinion.
I think it was amazing, I loved it.
It’s funny because I’ve just re-watched
it actually, the entire thing.Saramy
writing partner/producing partner and I were huge
fans and it’s just excellent. It’s like nothing
I’ve ever really seen on television before and
I thought the finale, especially on a re-watch,
was awesome. I could actually track…I
know a lot of people were upset that
I think the controversy was the character Daenerys
wouldn’t have retaliated exactly the way she did
but if you watch (and because we just did this)
if you watch all the seasons back-to-back you
can really see her aggression was always
there but people were keeping her in check
and then finally she just released it all. I
thought it was great. I love Game of Thrones.
Film Courage: So the ending was
satisfying to the two of you?
Jeremy: The ending was completely satisfying
for us yeah we loved it I know a lot of people
had their misgivings but I think if people it's
difficult because how can you please everybody
who watched it and and people loved it so much
I loved it so much that it's it's really hard to
I totally understand that I meet everyone's
expectations but I think on the re-watch
it it really is even better do you wish
that George RR Martin had completed
all of the books beforehand did you notice a
difference in the writing style so actually
i'd never read any of the books so I don't know
I've only been a fan of the television series
and I always loved the writing in that I do
know that people said I think some people I
knew had read some of the books but I've actually
never read any of them so I'm still a fan
in the end do you think any mistakes were
made with the final season I do think
the final season obviously was so big I mean every
episode was I think what 90 minutes long maybe
but again just it's all fresh in my
mind because I just saw them all but
I think every episode was just so huge and and
had so many battle sequences and just just really
big production stuff I think there was what
seven episodes and so maybe if they could have
had like maybe two or three more episodes two more
episodes um maybe it would have helped people feel
a little more um like like the character of
Daenerys had had had a little bit more of an
arc which I think people were reacting to so I
think I think they could have done that but for
the seven episodes and for how big they were and
for just what a spectacle like they were amazing
the battles and the the final
battle at Winterfell there
it was like the best television I’d ever
seen so I loved it I thought it was great and
now it totally satisfied me so the first time
the two of you watched the entirety of the of the
different seasons when you went to twitter
and you saw some of the outrage from the fans
what was your thought I just thought when
I went to after we had watched the finale
and we looked on twitter and saw
people were outraged I was a little
I was a little bit shocked
actually because it's just like
had been such an amazing show the entire time
and I just felt like people were kind of like
not taking all of that into consideration
but I think again you it's impossible to
please everybody and it's impossible to please
everybody on twitter the the the outrage and and
I thought it was just excellent I think people
were overreacting and again I think if people
watch it again and even watch the entire series
I think the the signs and the clues to what they
were reacting against were really always there um
and it's hard because game of thrones there would
be these huge gaps between seasons I remember like
what was it like a year or a year and a half even
so it's that's a long time and I think you
maybe you people would just maybe forget or just
just weren't remembering exactly but if you
watch them all back to back I think I think
all the signs were there so if you keep with
the theme of can't please everybody of course
what is your thought of of when a fandom has
so much opinion or or emotion over the outcome
of what a creator does or doesn't
do gosh it's so hard to say I think
it it is interesting to see especially in
our world with social media how like the the
reactions of the fans can actually affect
the final product of a film I mean that's
we've never seen that before right like not to my
knowledge I don't think there was ever anything
in the past where the the public would have as
big of a voice as they're having now because of
all this the twitter and facebook and whatever
else um I i don't know how to feel about it I
mean it's it's a very interesting thing where
it's like in some cases I think it probably has
helped and in some cases I'm sure it's hurt um
but but I know like for instance there was the
um the sonic the hedgehog movie and like people
were were really criticizing the design of the
first character and they modified it
and adjusted it and the second one and
the second one looked great I thought so maybe
that was a good thing and then I know there are
like there's also the outrage of like a show
like game of thrones where I thought it was
really excellent and I thought that it had been
such a awesome viewing experience and awesome
for an audience for like seven seasons and
then people were just upset and I just like
I don't know I don't think sometimes
people are taking into consideration
everything that came before it and they're just
reacting on literally what they saw an hour ago
Jeremy is there any way you could rank the seasons
of game of thrones from let's say the best season
to the worst season sure so if I had to rank the
game of thrones seasons highest to lowest um and
I'm a fan of them all I would start with season
six which I believe had the battle of the bastards
and Daenerys crossing this the the narrow sea at
the end of the season so six would be my highest
probably seven and then probably eight
because I do like towards the end there
where everything was really ramping up and
the stories were kind of tying up and so like
there was there was a lot of consequences a lot of
stakes for everybody I mean there was there was a
lot going on so I think those three six top then
seven then eight and then I mean I like them all
five I think is where Jon Snow got killed so I
really like five so I think six seven eight five
one two three because I gotta go with one since
like that's what kicked everything off so that
that'll go up there so yes six seven eight five
one two oh wait I missed five six seven eight five
four one two three that's my ranking so the
sixth season sixth season is your favorite yeah
i'll do six season at the top okay then season
seven then season eight then season five season
four and then season one two and three and why
three if you had to choose your least why is it
last one oh yeah we can give me a second okay I'm
sort of guessing on those last lines oh no okay
I don't want to wait wait
let me see let me see well
The fourth one let me see
Oathbreaker these are all great
Oh man, no the Red Wedding was in
[episode] three. I can’t put that last.
Oh boy! People will never forgive me.
Yeah that's very really funny I can't do
that so okay so my ranking would be season
six at the top season seven season eight
season five season four season three
season one and then season two at the bottom so
two was the least favorite I think two would be my
least favorite although I still totally
enjoyed it um maybe because things were still
getting going I gotta put one up there because
that's really what kicked off the entire season
or the entire series I should say and then um
yeah so maybe maybe season two would be my least
favorite but I still love them all big fan so
even though you'd never read the books the the
series started you heard word of mouth what was
about the world the world building that you loved
yeah it's interesting like we when we started
watching it I hadn't ever read the books
I just think it was very
unique of course it was like
I think that's that's what I really seized
on maybe like there were like sort of like
things like a medieval mythology like dragons and
I think those things were like alluded to but like
there were still things about it that like it
just felt new to me like there were obviously like
characters not behaving in ways
that I've sort of had seen before um
they were kind of like really like sort of like
kind of like mature themes in this sort of that
in this sort of like a medieval show or like that
sort of had those elements but there was like very
mature themes in it which I was like whoa like
I haven't I don't think I had seen that before
um and yeah like a lot of the characters seemed
very fresh very new I thought again all of the the
dialogue was really like really like layered and
really complex but also at times could be really
like kind of funny kind of sharply funny or like
humorous um so it just felt like really like fresh
something like really that I i felt like i'd never
seen anything that tackled it quite like that.
Question For The Viewers:
How would
you rank Game Of Thrones
seasons from best to worst?